so some of you are going back to
architecture school this week
and chances are you'll have a gazillion
things thrown at you and you're gonna be
expected somehow to have learned all of
these skills like sketching 3d modeling
presenting
while you were in high school you will
have to learn all of these skills
eventually
but i remember feeling extremely
overwhelmed by all of this although
every single one of these skills is very
important if there's one skill that's a
keystone skill meaning that once you've
mastered this everything will kind of
fall into place
it is
this is also a skill that's permanently
useful and will help you after you
graduate and ultimately it'll kind of
define your trademark as an architect
[Music]
hey guys welcome back to the channel if
you're new here my name is dami and i am
a licensed architect in beautiful
vancouver bc
on this channel we talk about
architecture and design and also some
tools and strategies to help us have
more meaningful and fulfilling careers
in architecture
if you haven't guessed already that
skill is
sketching this is going to be a short
one in this video i'm going to talk
about why this skill is so friggin
important
and how you can improve it every single
day so first reason the wow factor the
wow
so i'm gonna tell you a little secret
please do not judge me when i started
working in an architectural office as a
junior designer i used to print out my
3d models and sketch over it
and i would present the image and every
time the reactions were great and maybe
it's it is very inefficient and maybe
it's a little unorthodox but most people
don't question the method
they just see the result and sketching
is a lost art and it just has this wow
factor that renderings just can't
achieve these days
and it
allows you to focus on certain areas and
it also gives you leeway to leave
certain areas unresolved and over time
this little trick allowed me to sit and
draw with the bosses rather than doing
toilet layouts
second reason is speed so the other day
we had one of those rare
epiphany moments in our studio we are
working on a interior renovation and
because there are so many complex
existing elements in the space
we've been struggling to identify
an organizing strategy and one day
one of the partners of the firm came
back from visiting the project and
he said
okay
i think i got it and he sat down and he
overlayed some sketch paper on to the
plans
and he drew a series of lines and
squares and within five minutes that
single sketch communicated everything we
needed to know and we had kind of solved
the problem and honestly i wish this
wasn't the case but one of the things
that's going to make you a better
designer is your speed
and the speed in which you can
communicate your ideas and the speed in
which you can iterate through multiple
options and throw out the bad ones when
we're going through the design process
we're constantly presenting to our peers
our instructors our colleagues our
bosses
and despite 3d modeling and rendering
softwares
being
available and very popular
sketching is still the fastest method
for us to communicate our ideas and when
it comes to communication you don't need
to be a perfect drawer a drawer a drawer
a drawer a drawer a drawer a drawer a
drawer but you do need to be able to use
your drawings to express your ideas
clearly and quickly and third reason you
just become a better designer personally
i like to move into 3d modeling fairly
early in the design process because it
gives me a lot of flexibility in the
geometry and i can just iterate through
multiple options by doing like copy and
paste and with something like rhino or
sketchup i can experiment with like
conditions and material quality really
early on in the design process but
3d modeling can be very dangerous a very
dangerous trap if you don't know how to
use it properly i have wasted
many many
many hours
on rhino or sketchup because it's like
it's a black hole this usually happens
when i jump into 3d modeling too early
without a solid idea and i don't know
for some reason
time just seems to go by way faster when
i'm 3d modeling on the computer than
when i'm sketching on paper i don't know
if you guys feel that way too or maybe
i'm just crazy i also mentioned this on
my blog post i'll leave the link below
our cognitive abilities our brains just
function differently when we're using
our hands our hands
when i'm sketching i seem to be able to
generate better ideas so i usually go
back and forth between sketching and 3d
modeling when i started architecture
school my university recommended a
toolbox
which included all the architectural
supplies that i needed for doing the
work i found out later that it was a
little overpriced i've been working with
pacific arc on building an architectural
supplies kit that includes all of the
tools that you'll need in school
at a discounted price
you can use the code dammy lee for an
extra 30
discount on the kid so now i'm gonna
give you some tips that you can use to
improve your sketching every day so
first one is simple just make a point of
drawing something in your sketchbook
every single day if you're having an off
day and can't really think of anything
interesting you can use that day to
practice
sketching things like objects in your
surroundings find an object in your
surrounding and sketch that a simple
glass cup could be a starting point of a
bigger architectural concept you can
practice sketching materials and
textures figure out how you want to
represent materials and textures in your
sketches and this just adds life to your
drawings and because it's a simplified
representation of the real thing it's
really good to learn some standards on
how architects draw them it's quick it's
fun and it can help you develop your
personal style i would love to see your
progress so if you're drawing or
sketching
follow me on instagram and tag me if
you're struggling in the beginning do
not worry too much
i was a late bloomer and i didn't really
get it until my second year and until i
found a project i was really passionate
about but remember
passion is not something that you just
find it's a cultivated thing so you have
to keep trying keep practicing and don't
give up and try to lean into your
passions with that
good luck
if you enjoyed this video you might also
enjoy the video where i talk about some
life lessons that i knew when i was in
architecture school i'll leave the video
right here
and if you like this video please give
me a thumbs up
and i make more content about
architecture so if you're interested in
that and you are not subscribed
please subscribe i'll see you in the
next video
bye
[Music]
you